welcome to the last afternoon session of
the workshop and we are very delighted
to have tomorrow from georgia tech to
talk about random graphs imagine random
graph with constant creation so take
away
thank you for the introduction
so yeah today as this title suggests i'm
going to
give the third talk in this workshop
about graph matching and in particular
about the exam matching of the random
graphs with constant correlations and
this is joint work with mark rudolfson
from university of michigan and the
constantine tickerman who is my
colleague at georgia tech
both are very great probabilists who i
enjoy working with
okay so let me start with
just a quick recap of what the problem
of graph matching is
so here we have two unlabeled graphs a
and b
which are this blue graph and the red
graph on the left and
as you can see i mean they don't really
look similar to each other if you stare
at them and our goal is to
shuffle the
the vertices of the the first graph okay
so
our goal is to shuffle the vertices of
the first graph so that we can match
these vertices to the second graph and
put them on top of each other and if we
do this in an optimal way then
we see the graph on the right hand side
so the blue edges are the
common edges while the the green ones if
you can see them those are the
discrepant edges
okay so this is a problem
and
this this problem comes up with a
from a
bunch of applications for example uh in
social networks you can have a
network with some known users like
linkedin and you can have some an
anonymous network and if you
successfully match the nodes of these
networks using the graph topologies then
you can de-anonymize the anonymous
network that's why application and
for example in computational biology you
can also have
protein protein interaction networks
where you if you mount if you match the
mouse network to the human network then
you can do some experiments with a mouse
network to
discover some functions of the the
proteins in the human network right
like in computer vision you can also use
graphing to match shapes
so the way to do this is like you build
a
triangulated mesh graph on top of
each shape like this and you do the same
on the right hand side and
and once you have these two graphs you
can match the graphs in order to match
the two shapes and the advantage of
doing this is that the graph topology is
usually more robust to noise
uh
i mean it is more robust than the
euclidean geometry of the two shapes if
they are like deformable
okay so uh
so traditionally uh graph matching has
been formulated in the in deterministic
ways uh in particular the famous graph
isomorphism problem is just a
noiseless version of graph matching and
i mean even
i think
today the computational complexity has
not been settled in the worst case
and if there's noise you can
certainly formulate this as some
famous
hard problem called the quadratic
assignment problem
because if you have a and b which are
adjacency matrices of these two graphs
and then you can compute the common
edges as this sum right so here the
pi is a permutation
which acts on the rows and columns of
this
adjacency matrix so this is a
permutation of the vertices of the graph
a right and
this formula just counts the total
number of common edges
but unfortunately this formulation is
empty hard in the worst case
so
yes we need some models and
let me quickly
go over this model again although you
have seen this a couple of times
so here a and b are marginally gmp
graphs
they are supposed to be correlated
through a ground truth matching pi star
and um so there's only one key quantity
you need to remember which is the
noise level or the correlation
so here delta
is defined to be
the
probability where you have an edge in a
but it doesn't you don't have the
corresponding edge in b
so here pi star is the ground truth
matching so we are looking at the edge
denoted by pi star i pi star j in the
graph a
and the probability that b doesn't have
that edge is uh delta so delta is the
noise level between zero and one
or equivalently you can
see that if you take the just the
expectation of this
uh the product of these two edges is p
times y minus delta so 1 minus delta is
a correlation between these two graphs
right
and
giving a and b we aim to
recover this pi star and in particular i
will focus on exact recovery although i
mentioned here and there where partial
recovery is also possible
okay
so first when is exact recovery possible
so let me first remind you this
connectivity threshold of an early
training graph gmp
so as long as mp exceeds log n so here i
put a constant
slack here so epsilon is some fixed
constant larger than zero that can be
arbitrarily small
so as long as this
condition holds the the graph is
connected almost as surely as n goes to
infinity
so this gives
i guess a necessary condition for
exactly recovery to be possible that is
if we consider this so-called
intersection graph so we simply consider
the common edges of these two graphs
when they are matched
perfectly
and this is a
g n p times one minus delta
graph
and we need the intersection of them to
be
connected because if there are some
isolated vertices then you can shuffle
them
it's impossible to recover the
permutation
exactly
so so this gives a
basically a necessary condition for for
exact recovery
and yes so if you look at this condition
if mp is just a little bit above log n
here
then right hand side you have a log n
right if you cancel this you see that
as long as delta is a small constant
depending on epsilon
this equal inequality holds right so
that is basically
the goal of this talk
the goal of this target is that i'm
going to give a algorithm
such that under this condition
we can succeed successfully recover the
permutation
okay but before that let me just uh do a
review of the some selected results in
the literature
um
so first
i said that this condition is is almost
unnecessary right uh up to this uh
constant epsilon and it's actually also
sufficient as shown by
kulina kiyowash and also
ihon jaming here and sophie
here
so
i think there are more
more precise results in these papers but
i'm just
uh showing the the the main condition uh
which coincides with with the the one
that i showed earlier
but unfortunately this is through a
maximum likelihood estimation so which
is basically a quadratic assignment and
that takes the exponential time
uh and also uh barack adal showed um
a sub exponential time algorithm which
is still super pointing over time yes
a quality polynomial okay i apologize
for that uh yeah so it's a
end to the log n right okay
sorry about that uh
yeah so
the condition is that
still the correlation can actually if
you look at this one
the correlation can still be actually
close to zero in order for this to
succeed
which is um
great but still we don't have a point in
time algorithm yet um
if we move to a poly
time algorithm then the picture suddenly
starts to change because
we only know that when
the noise
delta
is smaller than something
vanishing
can we recover the permutation and this
is
a bit uh
a bit different from the situation when
uh we are allowed to to use the infinite
computational power right and especially
uh it seems
after
a lot of works it seems constant
threshold is is a bottleneck for
polynomial time algorithm i mean
although it's still a conjecture
so i think the point of our work is to
see that whether it's possible to
achieve constant threshold at least in
some regime right
and the regime we consider is that the
average degree
is above the connectivity threshold
but it's still
quite small so we're considering is
actually some sparse graph
and we show that uh well at least in in
this regime you can achieve constant
threshold so here
delta zero is some constant
that depends only on epsilon okay
okay so uh that is the the the purpose
of our our album yes
uh yes i'll get to that yeah
okay so let me just move to uh the
algorithm and the analysis
i sort of described the
analysis and the proofs along the way
okay
so
the general idea of this algorithm or a
rather class of algorithm is that
we want to associate some some signature
to each vertex in each graph
and we do this for
all the vertices in a and all the
vertices in b
and
if we take a pair of vertices
if this pair of signatures are close
enough then we match these two verses if
they are far apart then we don't match
so this is a general meta algorithm
but the point is that
how should we design this signature
right
so i guess the most naive
signature is the degree
but unfortunately this certainly doesn't
work
because
if you consider the concentration of the
degree it's the average
minus the standard deviation to average
plus a standard deviation
so
if you put n degrees in this small
buckets i mean you are certainly going
to have some
vertices with the same degrees so
there's no separation so you cannot use
the degrees to
as signatures right
so uh
so starting from there there are some
amazing works in the literature for
example uh one by by ihon xiaomi and
co-authors which you use is this
so-called degree profile so here degree
profile just means neighbors degrees so
we not only look at the degree of the
vertex uh i we also look at its
neighbors degrees and we use the
empirical distributions of the
neighbor's degrees to to
as a signature to to match
the vertices okay
but
this this algorithm requires vanishing
noise rather than a constant level
noise okay
another
work by by jamming and
alkanol mossel
studied the seeded version of the
problem so
it's it's just some variant of this
problem but they do achieve constant
noise and the idea is that
they use
the number of neighbors in a so-called
seed set
and um
they do not consider just the neighbors
but they consider the r neighbors where
this r will depend on the degree of the
graph
so in some sense this is a variation of
using degrees but
there are two differences why is that
you use degrees
in in a certain set the second
difference is that you consider
our hub neighbors not just those
immediate neighbors okay
um
i don't really want to get into this
details but uh
these are the
the the messages that i want to uh say
uh and also uh yesterday we saw uh mark
presented
their work about uh partial matching and
they also achieved the constant noise
and
the the way that they did this is to
consider certain local trees and if you
use these trees
local neighborhoods which are trees as
the signatures then by comparing these
local trees they can achieve constant
noise
and um
this the lesson here is that they
consider trees of depth uh i think of
all the log n
so this is not the their immediate
neighbors but they're rather a large
neighborhood right
so uh i guess the lesson from um these
papers and also other papers that i'm
not listening here is that
we can use degrees statistics but
they're not like playing degrees we have
to use them in some clever way and also
we do want to explore large
neighborhoods because
if you stop at
your
second neighbor third neighbor
yeah perhaps the
the noise condition is not going to be
constant but it's rather vanishing so we
want to explore large neighborhoods so
that we can
achieve constant noise
for this problem
okay so before
i start describing our algorithm let me
just uh
show you the the main theorem
so
if we observe this a and b with um this
latent matching called pi star so in
many places i will basically take pi
star to be the identity
just for simplicity
um
and we are focusing on this
regime where the average degree
is between is above the connectivity
threshold and below
n to the 1 over c log log n so this
condition will come up naturally in the
analysis
and the noise level is here so
the noise is smaller than some absolute
constant delta zero
and it has to be smaller than epsilon
over four
so if you look at the condition for
connected connectivity threshold delta
just has to be
a little bit smaller than epsilon so
here
this epsilon over 4 is something coming
from the proof which we didn't really
try to optimize
but the point is that
if epsilon is the small constant then
yeah we achieve the
best possible result up to a constant
okay
and our algorithm is
has run in time and and square although
this is not the focus of this talk
and we can recover
uh pi star with probability uh roughly
like 1 minus n2 negative epsilon so note
that
this cannot get improved because
basically when you have this condition
then the graph is connected only with
this probability so this is the best
probability that we can hope for in this
region okay
okay so let me start describing the
algorithm
so first
the algorithm is based on a key
construction called the
partition trees
so this is a central idea of the
algorithm i should say
so let me first
describe the structure of python even
before defining it
so here we fix the graph a and fix the
vertex i and we let
s i r to denote the r sphere of i
in the graph distance
okay and the partition tree is basically
some tree
rooted at i and it is a complete binary
tree meaning that um
okay let me draw it this way
meaning that uh it has
i has two children first right and then
uh
these two children
further have four children
but note that each node here is not a
vertex but rather
a set of vertices
and they are denoted by
t
r
sigma here t is a tree r is the oops
r is the depth so here this first node
is t 0
second level
or first level children
are called
t1
subscript plus one
and t1 subscript negative one right and
for the uh second level children we have
t
two
uh plus one plus one
and t two plus one minus one
t two minus one plus one and t two
minus one minus one okay
so uh they are in the indexed by
the sigma which is a binary vector of
length r
where r is level okay
and then uh
if you just look at
a fixed level then these nodes
form a partition of the r sphere
centered at
i okay
so this is a structure of this tree
okay
and
note that
i'm already restricting my attention to
the case where
uh the neighborhood of i is indeed the
tree and not only the neighborhood but
actually the m neighborhood
m is of size uh c times log log n where
c is just some constant
taken to be 22 in the paper actually um
so
uh
actually maybe you have already seen
where the condition on the upper bound
on the degree is coming from but i'll
get to that
okay so this is structure of the
partition tree
and what is the actual definition um so
notice that here i'm just redrawing the
tree here
and uh
so we're going to define the in an
iterative way we start from the vertex i
which is called t0
and i go downwards
for r from
zero to n minus one i and then define
each uh
each node in this uh level okay
okay and basically the idea is that uh i
define uh
a half first go to the first level i
define half of the nodes as
some high degree nodes so
these are high degree
while the other half of the nodes are
defined as low degree nodes so i split
the set of
first level children of i into two parts
one
according to their degrees and if you
look at the definition here
yeah so this is a condition where
you split
the children into two halves
and um
here i use n to denote the neighbor
uh of all vertices in a set as so
essentially given t in the r's level
index by sigma
i define
t r plus 1 sigma plus 1
as the children of
tr's of vertices in tr sigma
which have high degrees
and this intersection just means that uh
i'm only looking at uh
the the r plus one neighbors when i'm
defining the
nodes in
level r plus one industry but
this part will not appear when the it is
when the neighborhood of i is indeed a
tree okay
uh yes yes because
uh in reality uh
yeah it's i mean it's it's hard to tell
uh if your neighborhood is inventory or
not i mean it's not that hard but
we don't really need this extra step so
we just define this to be the playing
degree and this won't matter in the
analysis
for different segments they cannot
intersect because these two these are uh
this condition is never
simultaneously right so
i just mean for different sigma not for
i just mean that
let's see i have a sigma plus one and
also have a sigma prime plus one
no no
uh because okay so so inductively the
this so
these sets are indexed by sigmas right
and they form a partition by definition
they should not intersect
and the reason is that if i start from
here
if i already have a non-intersecting
partition of level r then if i define
sigma plus 1 as the index for the next
part
it won't intersect with
sigma minus 1 right
and for
and
this this will also
be destroyed from that one
because
this set is the neighbor index by sigma
uh
in the previous level right and this
part is uh this part consists of
vertices which are neighbors
uh
from
from their parents so if these two sets
do not intersect these two sets
will not intersect
oh yes yes yes yes
um
let me see
no actually actually i'm guaranteeing
this to be a tree because i have this
intersection here so if i if i do not
have this intersection maybe you will
have some conflict but if i i force
myself to look at the tree
then you can consider a square if you do
not actually square basically
okay you're all right yes yes sorry
sorry about that yes yes so
we will uh
restrict our attention to trees yes
that's actually a very good point yes
i'm just drawing trees directly but
you're right yes
okay so it okay so if if the
neighborhood of i is a tree um is does
that definition make sense okay
so i think this is the most important
thing you need to take from this talk so
yeah please ask any questions
okay
all right so if we define the
partition trees
of uh neighbor of vertices in these two
graphs then what matters is the
intersection right
then
it's actually easy to analyze the
intersection uh for for children
because uh okay so so now i'm
restricting to certain typical versus i
so i'm
i describe what typical means in the
next two slides
so
[Music]
here because the size of neighborhood is
roughly
np
and we roughly split them into half half
so we have
the
the nodes in the first level
have size mp over two right
and because the two graphs have
correlation delta
the intersection
between
the corresponding
nodes of the partition trees in these
two graphs
have intersection the typical size times
one minus the noise or one uh yes and
here i mean this is for the first
neighborhood i mean this has a simple
expression but when we iterate uh
basically this is some quantity that
depends on delta and the important thing
is that it goes to zero as delta goes to
zero if i let the noise uh to be very
small then this this will always be very
small okay
so
yeah basically it's saying that uh
this set overlaps with this that that a
lot okay
okay so um
now this is the intersection in the
first level children now i can move on
to
level m
well actually here typical precisely
means the m neighborhood of iso3
along with other
five six conditions which i'm not
listing here
and the same story continuous told
basically it's saying that the
m's neighborhood of i or rather m sphere
of i has size mp to the power m
and if we split them into
2 to the m buckets
then the average size is mp over 2 to
the m
for for each of them
okay
now if i consider the intersection
between this
node
in the tree with that node in the tree
in the two different graphs then the
intersection
the factor in the intersection also
gets powered to the amps power here
right
so um
in the amps level uh
these two cells still
overlap but the the fraction of the
overlap is getting smaller but still
non-trivial that's the key so it's 1
minus
capital
to the power m
okay
and
how many typical vertices are there
um it's actually not hard to show if you
have some probabilities
uh forensic probability right so
we can show that
if the average degree is between
log n and
n to the one over some super large
constant times log log n if and if we
only consider
m
of size some constant times log log n
and if c prime larger than c
um yeah maybe you put some 100 here then
you can show that
the neighborhood of i
is
likely a tree right
and basically we show that with the
probability
1 minus n to some power negative power
then
most vertices are
have neighborhoods which are trees
and i mean this this part is not the
super precise because it doesn't have to
be the the message is basically most
vertices are typical and their
neighborhoods are trees okay
and the conclusion is that um
if
this condition holds note that here the
actually
the part one plus epsilon
haven't come in yet
so
and also
this constant times log n is not
essential maybe we can have 0.1 log n
so this part actually holds for for
partial matching rather than exam exam
action because we are already looking at
typical vertices rather than all of the
vertices right
okay
under this condition for these typical
vertices
um leaves of the partition trees
uh at a in
at i in the first
graph and at i in the second graph they
have overlap
which is the typical size times this
factor which appeared earlier right and
this factor will be important and i'll
explain
in a few slides
and also you want to bound the
intersection between leaves of partition
trees
at i in a and j in b where i is not
equal to j and you want to show that
they have tiny overlaps so that
you can distinguish i and j from these
partition trees and okay so this is a
conclusion of the the first part
okay
all right so
let's come to the second part
which is about how we actually define
the vertex signature that i promised
earlier
so
again we have a graph a and a vertex i
so i will define the signature to be a
vector in dimension r to the 2 to the m
this is because i will naturally index
the
entries of this signature by the the
leaves in this partition tree okay
so
i mean actually they are both indexed by
by this sigma which is a binary vector
in dimension m okay
and uh i should say that
the definition of this signature here is
not that important because uh i mean we
have various ways to define and they all
achieve the same results basically
because as long as you have correlation
between the leaves of the potential
trees you can define the signatures to
be some reasonable quantity to capture
this correlation
and here we specifically define it to be
a sum of degrees
of
neighbors
of leaves of this partition tree
so
it's like going another two steps down
the tree right um
which which is sort of natural once you
have already constructed this partition
trigger
but again i think this part is not the
key
okay so but but the key is that
because the leaves of the participants
are correlated they have overlaps
so if i consider the entry wise
differences
between vertex signatures from these two
graphs then they are they are actually
smaller than the typical size
so note that if i take i not equal to j
and i consider
i in a and g in b
if i consider the square difference uh
of entry sigma
between these
vertex signatures and i normalize by
by the appropriate variance so these are
all like explicit constants
and i can normalize it to have a
size one
but because
if i consider i and i from
these two graphs that should be matched
then if i normalize by the same variance
that is slightly smaller than one and
that
that factor here um
it precisely comes from the
overlap of the leaves of this particular
trees okay and um
okay so so this is where we actually
gain some
correlation between the vertex
signatures
and okay so here we can discuss how
large this quantity is so it's basically
um
because m is again m is
let's say we have 20 log log n
so if
delta
small
kappa delta small
then
this quantity can be
taken to be like a log
to the negative point one right
which is uh larger than one over roo log
n right so i mean while we're root
locking it's not essential i just pick
some threshold here okay
and this turns out to be the one
threshold that separates the the
correlated part from the uncorrelated
part okay
okay and
but that's not the whole story about the
signatures so
the
the
i mean the slight difficulty here is
that
the entries of the signatures are
correlated um because of some crazy
intersections in these graphs and here's
a
important idea which is spark
specification so this means that uh
so usually given entrywise difference
let's just take the l2 difference right
but here if you take l2 the dependency
becomes a bit crazy and
we instead take a uniform random subset
of the index set which is this binary
vector of the mesh m right
and this
crucially this index set i has size um
still poly login but it's much larger
much smaller than
the entire length of this signature
vector so that when we compare the
difference of two signature vectors
we consider a a specified set of entries
okay and then we consider this specified
um
l2 difference okay
but still i mean if you look at this
this is simply average so the the
threshold
stays the same so
this is our final
threshold for for
comparing vertices to decide whether we
want to match two vertices or or not
right
yes
oh because the if you just consider the
whole uh
like sigma in
this okay
for different sigmas
these quantities are correlated
so if you take a specified subset the
correlation becomes weaker
so this is actually not a very natural
idea actually
but it turns out to work
for each signal
no for i take a random subset of sigmas
so i select the subset of sigma so i is
the
sigma
right i is the subset of uh
uh
yes okay so sorry i guess what i meant
is for a pair ij so is it is this i
drawn for the entire uh thing or you do
you redraw it uh we don't redraw it okay
so we just went with once more the
entire thing yes okay thanks okay
okay
okay so the conclusion of this part is
that again
in the same regime
for the average degree
as long as delta is smaller than some
absolute constant
therefore typical vertices
they are correctly matched
and from there it's not hard to
show that we can obtain almost the exact
matching uh let's call it pi pi hat and
if we compare it to the true matching
and we consider the
number of discrepancies between these
two matchings is bounded by
some some quantity which is much smaller
than n
and this is coming from the
that part for typical vertices okay
okay so now we have a almost exact
matching
the problem is uh then how to refine
that to a exact matching so um
so this part is actually um i should say
uh
less difficult and less involved
so let's consider a refinement for one
step so how do we do this the idea is
very natural so in fact here
the assumption can be much weaker we
don't even have to have almost exact
matching we just need to have a partial
matching where we have a constant
fraction of the errors so here this is
the errors and let's say pi 0 is a
initial matching and in the actual
algorithm we simply take pi 0 to be the
almost exact matching pi star pi hat
from the previous step okay
all right so given this pi zero uh what
we do is that um so this might look a
bit complicated
but if you
let's look at the first line
let's just consider the neighbors of i
in a and consider the neighbors of j in
b
and because we don't know the matching
we just use the initial matching pi star
as imagine between them right
and if we compare the two neighborhoods
if they exceed some thresholds
then i match them okay
so that's very simple right just just by
comparing one neighborhoods of these
vertices
and
these two lines just guarantee that uh i
don't want to do things
in a wrong way so i not only compare
i
with j i actually compare i with all the
other vertices of b
so for all k not equal to j in in this
graph b um the
the intersection of neighborhood has to
be smaller and i also do the same
uh for for all k not equal to i in the
first graph right
and okay so if uh using this
intersection of neighborhood uh
then that gives us some um
potential matching which we call pi one
okay
so uh if you just do this the the
matching won't be um
won't be an actual uh permutation so we
just extend it to a permutation in a
rather arbitrary way
and then this gives me a one-step
refinement okay
and now we just do this uh multiple
times so why we can't do this
iteratively
to recover the exam matching well that's
because
uh for this step uh with probability
n to the
negative epsilon over ten so this is
where the
uh the worst uh
error probability comes into the picture
okay and if the for the previous
matching
the
fraction of error is like
lambda n
then for the next matching we can show
that
we basically have the
the arrow fraction here
and therefore if we just do
this l times then
the error becomes lambda
n divided by 2 to the l where we do it l
times and we just iterate this
log base 2 n times now we get the exact
matching okay
this is how the
iterative refinement goes
okay and the conclusion is that
if the average degree is above
one plus epsilon times log n and below
below
root n
with some factor here so this this part
comes from the analysis of intersection
of neighborhoods because
we are considering uh the
neighborhoods of two vertices and in
order for them to have a very small
intersection i mean it turns out this is
the condition we need to impose but i
mean this is much weaker than the
average degree condition from the first
part right
and and also in this analysis uh turns
out we need to take uh the noise level
to be smaller than epsilon over four
okay
and the point is that starting from some
partial matching
we can exactly recover pi star with high
probability but here
note that the difference
between your euro refinement
of partial matching is that um
this partial matching might be data
dependent
um because pi hat is computed from our
um
to graphs right so
there might be dependencies that
you want to control but here actually
we just consider the initial partial
matching at some adversarial imaging it
can be anything okay and i think this
part
this type of analysis actually came up
in
i think in iho and jamie's paper also
previous work on this um
although here we do need the slightly
stronger result okay
okay cool
so by combining everything um
we have
our mean theorem stated again so
again so this average degree so this
condition comes from the second part of
refinement
that upper bound on the average degree
comes from the first part of building
the partition trees
and
this part
delta smaller than some absolute
constant coming from the partition trees
while delta smaller than epsilon over
four is coming from the refinement step
right
so this is how we uh
why we have this final result and um
yeah i should say if you just look at
the algorithms carefully because the
graphs are sparse you can do all sorts
of operations in time and to the two
plus some little of one okay
okay so
maybe i guess it's a time to
discuss some
future directions or works i i do think
there are a lot of things to to explore
along this line of research so first
about the theory of early training graph
patching
i should say that
this is definitely not the end of the
analysis of early training graphs
because um yeah we rather
focused on the sparse regime and for
dense graphs
they are supposed to be easier to match
because if you
look at
this condition again
if mp is very large
then one minus delta can be extremely
small meaning that the correlation can
be extremely small and the noise delta
can be extremely close to one right so
there's a huge gap
between what can be achieved the
information's relatively and uh
algorithmically but
um
i mean i don't know where the threshold
is maybe it's a constant delta maybe
it's like something logarithmically i
don't know
and
even other than that i think um
for example from mark's talk yesterday
about the partial recovery and um there
also lines of works by um
by sophie yoho and jamie here on
detection so i think all these are
interesting problems in particular i
think uh
we are supposed to have a new paper
which
shows some
potential
conjectured lower bound for for this
problem
regarding this noise level delta
and there are also variations for
example you can have a cd version which
i mentioned earlier
and you can incorporate all sorts of
side information into the model because
in practice
if you consider a graph maybe you have
some features for all these nodes
and then you can do the matching better
using both the
network topology and the features of the
nodes right
so
i think this part is actually
missing in the literature i mean there
are some papers but uh
i think
this deserves to be explored a lot more
and
yeah and furthermore there are some uh
other random graph matching models for
example we did some earlier work
on universality of
certain methods and
um
but there are also interesting models
which do not fall into this universality
class for example the preferential
attachment model which was considered by
by nicholas here and
again by nicholas about this correlated
the stochastic model which was presented
earlier this week
so that ends my talk thank you
take your time for the great talk any
questions
yes
so in the construction of the signature
would you mind go back to that part so
do you need to show that for fake pairs
uh the signature based matching fails
with probability less than one over n
no no that's not what we do okay let me
yeah okay so you're not taking a union
bound over everyone
no let me explain a bit what we do so
uh
i mean we are taking a union bound but
we are taking union bound within the
within the typical vertices which happen
with high probability so it's like we
have um
yeah we have some typical vertices which
lastly can be matched exactly and
so this is called say t for typical
vertices and we we do analysis here uh
with union bounds and the probabilities
are also
all pretty high oops
and there are some creative vertices
which uh yeah they can be connected
anyway or they can even connect it to
this typical vertices uh but uh yeah
we'll just
ignore that sure so you need this to
succeed for fail with less than one over
t
but t is almost n right t is almost n so
i don't understand uh
oh use okay so
[Music]
okay so there is some algorithm to okay
so let me say that
so i can guarantee that within the set t
uh there are
all the edges are correct right so you
are worried about uh
there are some edges from t complement
to t
which no i just meant you know f i j if
i
compared to f j right yeah yes yes for
each eye there is a
most of the j's are but for for things
in t would we do universe yes
right and then size of t is n minus some
little yes yes there we do a unit bound
over
n yeah i mean it can be n to any
constant power sure so you need this to
succeed with probably like one minus a
little one over n
uh yes but for for typical vertices this
succeeds with probability n to the
negative 100 so oh i see so this is this
because i is randomly sampled
sigmas is sufficiently large
randomly some uh
uh yes yes that part also holds with
high probability yes okay thank you okay
great
[Music]
any other questions
yeah i actually do want to curve a
little bit further so this is like the
mean square divided by variance
so i can see that
um but then how you can actually show
this high probability
like uh like you want to bounce oh okay
so i guess yeah
so uh
yes so i think this is not rigorous so
this is i'm just giving you some
intuition about the android thing the
high priority part is coming from here
okay and uh the high priority coming
from the fact that we take i to besides
poly login
okay so it's like a two to the poly log
n is a pretty large right so i see and
then and then in this case like you do
not make any matching errors like in
this first stage when you do partial
matching uh
matching errors so like
yeah like you do not match fake pairs i
just want
inside the set uh
typical vertices we do not make any
errors but outside we do make errors i
see and then your l1 actually cannot
really distinguish whether it's a
typical uh no no
any other questions
uh thanks for the nice talk so i'm just
wondering if you can provide some amount
of intuition for
the construction of this
partition tree and this particular
choice of the signature and sort of why
you expected this
uh to work or yes i don't know if i
understand the patient yeah okay so
um
that's a good question let me see how
uh i think uh okay let me go to the page
about the lessons
we learned from previous work
yeah so first we want to use degrees
okay second if we use degrees in a very
precise way for example in this degree
profile paper then it turns out it's
hard to iterate
so i think in this paper they analyze
like three neighborhoods so neighbors
degree profiles and turns out to be
extremely complicated so i think we want
to use degree in the rather close way so
if we just define this
partition into high degree versus the
loading reverses
this is actually not precise if you just
do it this one step right but because uh
this is uh not precise but it's sort of
the analysis like it's like more robust
because we're considering sets rather
than vertices if you consider
neighborhoods which are trees
if one edge breaks then it causes a
large error but if you consider uh
this tree which is a which consists of
sets they like will intersect with high
probability so this is like a closer but
more robust and because like this is a
more robust we can iterate it
to
m neighborhoods and then
it turns out the
going deep is what matters it's not like
you need to do some super refined
analysis
with within close neighborhoods large
neighborhoods matters
so is there some
way to if you're going large
neighborhoods is there some spectral
operator that this kind of would
correspond to
it could be i don't know okay that's a
that's an interesting point
thanks
maybe we can have one more questions
so um
for the first step you get almost exact
recovery uh
and that's even for any constant login
or
uh constantly so you don't need the the
one that's on login yes um so you also
get um
like a partial recovery for like
constant degree constant average uh
that's a good point uh no no we don't
have any concrete result there but uh we
think that that might be possible
because it seems like it could yeah so
yeah yes my next question would have
been how does that compare with the
ganasali
because it seems like they're related um
yes yes i think they are related and uh
yeah i mean we just didn't do constant
degree so i actually say that uh
i think pushing this to some small
constant times log n is easy so most
lemmas in the paper goes through but if
you put this to be some c
uh yeah then i think it's
more delicate actually i don't know yeah
thank you
okay maybe we can take the rest of the
question offline and thanks again for
the great thought
[Applause]
and let's also have